defensive head coaches in the afc each
which doesn't belong and why shawn
mcdermott of the bills brian flores of
the dolphins or robert saul of the jets
well i i mean obviously i'm going to go
with robert salah here as of right now
because it's his first time as a head
coach and we he's unproven i mean brian
flores is
is at least proven right now that hey
he's he's a pretty damn good head coach
they went 10-6 as a rebuilding football
team mcdermott's been in the running for
coach of the year and could have been
that last year so i'll go with solo
there right now who's unproven as a head
coach
yeah i'm gonna go with flores in a
positive way he's got the belichick
imprint and i look i don't want to take
anything away from the other two guys i
just see the potential for true
greatness in brian flores i like all
time greatness i see it i see it and
we've only had two seasons of exposure
but the way he carries himself the way
he interacts with players remember that
moment
in that bengals dolphins game when the
bengals player kept plowing into jakeem
grant and brian flores was ready to go
out there and kick the crap out of
somebody you know remember that oh
there's just
i would've met up with him you couldn't
pay me to mess with him you couldn't
i'll tell you a story he's running
the scout team defense while i'm in new
england now i'm not even out on the
practice field i'm noticing this on film
all right because i i have to like put
the plays into the the system so when
people watch the practice film the plays
jump out on the screen so they go okay
this is this play blah blah blah
there was
like a moment where they're holding up
practice
and the center and the offensive line
kind of want to go but like he doesn't
have his scout team defense organized
quite yet so he's kind of put his foot
on the ball to basically say like hey
hold on a second here and the center
cuts like keeps moving the ball and he
keeps moving it back and keeps moving
the ball and keeps moving it back and
i'm telling you they kind of got into it
not like punches but got into it and i
mean it was it's a stalemate i wouldn't
mess with him with anything he'd kick
the crap out of just about every coach
in football except for maybe mike vrabel
and i still think that'd be a good one
you know hometown and mike tyson don't
mess with him
there's plenty of coaches like that but
but that's just one piece of it there's
just something yes something there's a
spark there's something there that i
think is going to put him
over the passage of time on the short
list of all-time great coaches i hope
there's a high bar he's got a lot to
he's got a lot of work to do to prove me
right and i hope i live long enough to
see it all right patriots starter
potentially returning from opt out which
doesn't belong and why right tackle
marcus cannon linebacker dante had tower
safety patrick chung which doesn't
belong and why
um
all right well they need linebacker help
hightower is so versatile so to me he
belongs marcus cannon you infuse him
back into that offensive line and i go
that might be the best offensive line in
football in a lot of ways especially run
blocking i think the one i'll go with is
patrick chung i could see him at this
point of his career kind of being on the
outside looking in because also is
awesome in the legend he's been i mean
they got secondary guys you know growing
on trees there in new england and they
have a lot of safeties on their roster
too so i'll say he's the guy that could
be the odd man out here
i i'm gonna say hightower doesn't belong
because he's the guy who infuses
leadership back into the team the moment
he steps foot into the locker room and
he'll be able to explain you know to the
extent that any of the teammates need an
explanation as to why he opted out based
on the information that was available in
august they made the decisions they had
to make even though it ultimately worked
out and it wasn't nearly as bad for the
nfl as we thought it was going to be
they made the decisions they had to make
he brings leadership that is desperately
needed on the defensive side of the ball
he's the guy they need back more than
the other two so he stands out for me
patriots offensive free agents which
doesn't belong in y running back james
white guard joe thuney and center david
andrews well you know the
i guess this is another tough one these
are good ones by pete i think the one
i'm gonna go with is james white uh that
i mean joe thuney of course is is my kid
franchise tag second year in a row i
don't know where that's gonna go he's
one of the best run blocking
guards in all of football and of course
we know that's the strength of their
team running the football they need him
andrews is a good center not a great
center a good one you know the running
back james white he's a third down
specialist type guy
i always feel like they could they find
those guys they know where to find them
so i i think that's the one that doesn't
belong belong to me
well i and and look the problem with
tagging thuney again you're talking
about a 20 increase over the tag amount
from last year yeah so what's that going
to do
they can do it they i got to see what he
made last year but it's got to be around
15 16 million they've got the cab space
but even the teams with cap space just
because you have a lot of cap space that
doesn't mean you fritter it away oh well
let's go ahead and let's go ahead and be
drinking soldiers with our drunken
sailors or drunken soldiers both get
drunk with our cap money with our cap
money let's yeah you still want to be
careful with it and make it go as far as
it can in this climate where you can go
out and get a lot of uh a lot of players
17.7 million is what they would be
paying
an interior offensive lineman on a
one-year contract with no guarantee that
you know next year it's quarterback
money i know the third franchise tag
it's either a 44 bump or the quarterback
tag so i don't think that that is going
to be a long-term relationship unless
they get a long-term deal done sooner
rather than later sorry and i was just
going to say and to to your point which
you you make a very good point is like
you know a guy like marcus cannon who we
just talked about in there that that's
going to give them a little more
flexibility too you know on that offense
oh he's back okay maybe we're not as
desperate to keep one of those two
i would think they do everything they
can to get a long-term deal done with
joe thuney but you're right that's
that's pretty expensive one year type of
thing i don't know if i see new england
doing that or not
one more real quickly bill's free agent
starters guard john feliciano right
tackle daryl williams linebacker matt
milano which doesn't belong in why gosh
they uh all three are are pretty good
football players
you know i i
i'm gonna i'll go with matt milano here
you know again it's a i really like matt
milano the football player i guess where
i look at it is what kind of money is he
going to get on the the free agent
market he's a really good football
player who's been
he's an undersized middle linebacker
who's been banged up a little bit that's
scary and they got a guy like tremaine
edmonds who's we know is a you know top
15 pick or whatever that
that they're gonna have to pay him at
some point too so i i think that it
might be hard for them to keep matt
milano
i think it's more important to keep your
offensive line in place you can't
especially and you know there was a time
where
not a lot of value was placed on
interior offensive line but it's
critical to have good interior offensive
alignments so they're not blasting
through the middle and coming after josh
allen i think when you have that that
product that talent that quarterback in
josh allen you prioritize his blockers
that's why milano doesn't belong because
i think it's imperative to ensure that
they've got five guys no weak spots in a
position to protect josh allen as best
as they possibly can
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports